si hoy Estaba previsto que ese Jurado se
reuniera aquí en la corte criminal de
Manhattan en la tarde de este miércoles
Pero según Fuentes cercanas al caso
Parece ser que el fiscal del distrito de
Manhattan les ha pedido que hoy no
vengan hasta aquí todavía no sabemos el
porqué de esta decisión y cómo va a
afectar al proceso que se está llevando
a cabo como hemos dicho Alguna vez se
trata de un Jurado investigador de un
gran Jurado cuyas actuaciones son
secretas y por eso está siendo muy
complicado confirmar cada información y
poder hacer un seguimiento de cada paso
que se realiza de momento aquí sigue
habiendo un gran despliegue de policías
de seguridad para que en caso de que
haya algún tipo de manifestación
violenta pues se pueda contener un gran
despliegue de medios de comunicación
también lo que estamos viendo todavía
son pocos seguidores de Donald Trump a
las puertas de esta corte y la última
información que hemos conocido también
en el día de hoy En referencia a este
caso es que al parecer el abogado de
stormi Daniel se habría entregado una
documentación
al fiscal del distrito de Manhattan
donde se ve unas comunicaciones entre el
abogado de Donald Trump yo tacopina y
stormy Daniels digo presuntamente estas
comunicaciones porque el abogado de
Donald Trump lo niega dice que nunca ha
tenido comunicación ni ha hablado
directamente con Story Daniels y además
dice también que esto no puede afectar a
este proceso por qué hace hincapié en
eso Porque algunos expertos aquí están
apuntando a que quizá el juez podría
decidir apartar al abogado de Donald
Trump del caso y esto podría ralentizar
todavía más esa votación que estamos
esperando por parte del Jurado Que tiene
que decidir si acusa no a Donald Trump
si el juez toma esta decisión o no será
algo que tendrá que evaluar el mismo una
vez haya analizado las comunicaciones de
momento aquí seguimos muy pendientes de
lo que pueda pasar en las próximas horas
y en los próximos días porque ahora
mismo No hay ninguna fecha ni tiempo
concreto de cuando sabremos más
información acerca de esa votación del
Jurado